[Music]
very exciting news for Star Wars fans
there's a new TV series coming this fall
and I have the details Lucasfilm
announced Thursday Star Wars resistance
is the name of the anime inspired series
following Kazuto Zeo know a young pilot
recruited by the resistance and tasked
with a top-secret mission to spy on the
growing threat of the first border don't
the done right from rebels to the
resistance the series will take place
prior to the events of the force awakens
which means bb-8 Poe Dameron and Captain
phasma are all in the mix and yes Oscar
Isaac and Gwendoline Christie are
returning to reprise their voice roles
but there are plenty of newcomers
joining the resistance the voice cast
includes Christopher Shawn Bobby
Moynihan Jim rash and Donald Faison just
to name a few which I knew something was
up because Donald Faison was in the
audience of the Star Wars rebels series
finale was asking all these questions to
Dave Filoni during the Q&A like an
audience Easter egg we knew we were on
to you and if you did watch Star Wars
rebels by the way which recently ended
you'll be happy to know Star Wars
resistance is also created by Dave
Filoni in a statement falow niece ed the
idea for resistance which I'm sure we're
gonna start calling it came from his
interest in world war ii aircraft and
fighter pilots quote my grandfather was
a pilot and my uncle flew and restored
planes so that's been a big influence on
me there's a long history of high speed
racing in Star Wars and I think we've
captured that sense of excitement in an
anime inspired style which is something
the entire team has been wanting to do
for a long time and knowing Fallone ease
work we're probably gonna get sometimes
to the current sequel trilogy as time
goes on so I want to know who or what
would you love to see in the show my
initial thought if it makes sense to do
would be more of page tico from the last
Jedi I mean we left her need some more
but let us know what your thoughts are
in the comments or you can tweet me the
series will debut this fall on Disney
Channel in the u.s. before heading to
Disney XD that's where rebels lived and
around the
world may the force be with you
[Music]